Brenda's with us in Phoenix Arizona hi
Brenda how are you hi call sure what's
up in your world well we're in a big
mess I just started listening to you
later about a couple months I read your
book some money makeover and my um my
question is I have a lot of people tell
me I should just do bankruptcy and I
don't wanna go that route and I'd be
like me listening to you so I wanted to
if where am I at
I have babysit one I got my thousand
dollars I'm safe okay how much debt do
you have I have um I have a home I could
be from six years ago a hundred thousand
mm-hmm six years ago is just is it you
still have the home no we lost the home
but the home equity we bought if we get
that hundred to buy the second home
which we lost four homes six years ago
okay so you're a hundred thousand on
that and have you been paying on that no
how long has it been in default its six
years you've not paid on it in six years
no okay what else I have a $40,000
medical from two years ago and haven't
paid on it in two years nope nothing and
my dad eighteen thousand dollars in
credit cards and they are in collections
now so for the last six years
we have not done anything okay have you
been paying on the credit cards when was
the last time you paid on them I haven't
paid for the last five years okay and I
do have two credit cards for assuming
you know you know there's any papers
baby food women they're sending the
women they actually sent you lawsuit
papers or a letter saying they were
going to sue you mmm they're from a law
firm that doesn't matter was it an
actual lawsuit
long court documents that said you had a
court date yes it was we didn't go home
last year okay and and how much are
those two cards those are five thousand
and that's part of the eighteen or is
that in addition to the eighteen what is
your household income Oh myself
employing with the average of every year
about sixty thousand so why have you not
paid bills I don't know I don't know we
just I don't know we don't we just I
don't know we kind of just hide under
and didn't take care of it you know we
are you know we're being renting for the
last since we lost our home
no we I would like to move on and you
know filing a bankruptcy would clear
this hundred and fifty eight thousand
dollars in debt okay that it looks like
you've got it would clear that at
chapter seven would clear that I'm not
sure you're going to qualify for a
chapter seven it might the means test
might throw you into a chapter thirteen
which would cause you to pay payments
into bankruptcy for five years
are you II what was is his income steady
at sixty-five or is he starting to
increase his income it goes up and down
are you working outside the home now I'm
at the position like award my kids are
now are going to school and I'm able to
get a job you know in the morning you
know she's the job is weird so different
hours different schedules so I'm doing
one can run the kid around so I'm
considering ending the job you need to
add some income if you can add twenty
thirty thousand dollars income to this
situation it changes everything
yeah okay so here's the thing if we add
up all that debt and say it's one
hundred and fifty eight thousand hundred
sixty thousand dollars for the debt
it is very very old debt by and large
they have given up on it even the one
that serves you even the one that suits
you isn't doing anything with the
lawsuit they just took a judgment
against you but they're not doing
anything with it meaning they've not
come and garnished wages they've not
come and try to take money out of your
bank account or anything like that so
you know they're not they're not being
that aggressive or proactive I mean
they're probably calling you
occasionally some of them in raising
Cain but they're not actually doing
anything you follow me and the debt has
probably been sold and if it's been sold
a lot of it's been sold to debt buyers
and they buy that at around a nickel on
the dollar mm-hmm five cents on the
dollar
okay fifty dollars for a thousand
dollars you follow me which means that
if you made them an offer of ten or
fifteen cents on the dollar you could
clear all this debt and I would take a
lot of work to contact each one of them
negotiate with them get them to accept
that but eventually you could work your
way through this for around ten or
fifteen cents on the dollar
no the home equity they send me enough
for last year for twenty five thousand
to say that's a quarter on the dollar
they're already closed but you don't
have twenty five thousand so you'd have
to save up the money to make them an
offer they're going to be the hardest
one starting so you'd have to save up
you need a lump sum in your bank account
and then you call them and go
I have $15,000 cash I will give you
today if you will settle this and
they'll take it they'll take it but
they're not gonna take it easy they're
gonna whine and try to negotiate try to
get more go back and forth and the same
is true with these others so that tells
us that it will take you two years of
hard work and saving and negotiating and
fighting and scrapping and arguing with
these people and getting it all in
writing all these different accounts
okay
it's a lot of administrative work for
you but if you did that for two years
you can clear this debt for somewhere
around twenty twenty-five thousand
dollars
total and you could you save up a little
bit clear one save up a little bit clear
one save up a little bit clear one and
you know the last one is the home equity
loan and you save up fifteen thousand
and boom you knock it out okay
that's your alternative to bankruptcy or
you can file bankruptcy either one but I
I think you can work through it but you
really have a lot of work ahead of you
to work through it but I think you can
do that you're broke you don't have any
money as you save up money you call and
negotiate with them now if you're gonna
go that route make sure any settlement
you agree to that they agree to before
you give them any money two things you
have to remember get it in writing and
never an electronic access on your
checking account always in writing and
don't let them have access to your
checking account and don't give them any
information about where your husband
works or where you bank or anything like
that you have to stay stay in the
distance in the fog and negotiate with
them this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]